ladies I've heard you both use the term
fresh eyes and I'm wondering what that
means in relation to documentary
filmmaking and how important that is
well we tried and we try to make our
films always with fresh eyes if we can't
get fresh eyes on a film we probably
won't make it which means that we want
to take on subjects that are deeply
interesting to us we're fascinated by
that we don't feel like we know
everything about so it starts with a
really deep curiosity and we have to go
in just asking questions not with an
agenda and so that's what we mean by
fresh eyes just sort of a brand new
perspective we're listening to what you
have to say we're not taking any
position or judging necessarily we just
want to hear what a character has to say
or what a story is so that's what we
mean by fresh eyes I was thinking it
meant more that you had feedback on a
rough cut or something so no it means
more as it pertains to you both fresh
eyes in terms of your curiosity not well
someone's receiving your rough cut of
something another yes oh yes of course
well we don't want fresh eyes on on that
too because you do lose perspective when
you're editing so yes we like other
people's fresh eyes on our work and to
give us feedback but what Heidi's
describing is also you can call it the
beginner's mind which is when you when
you have no idea what someone's answer
is going to be and you should always
kind of be in that place especially at
the beginning of a project if you
already know what people are going to
say you're gonna get sick of it you're
going to you're gonna peter out on the
subject matter so that's why you want to
have the beginner's mind and if you can
maintain it for a while you're gonna
enjoy making this film you're gonna be
curious enough to you know keep the
momentum going back to curiosity which
is more crucial and interesting topic
but a reluctant or maybe not fully
developed subject for whatever reason or
the reverse a fascinating person but a
topic that's maybe more vague and a
little bit too broad well we don't make
films about topics we're very careful
not to come up with a topic and then try
to back into it but
it's it's important to have subject
matter that is rich and has depth that
it could be full of surprises and twists
and turns but it doesn't matter if you
have that an in-depth topic if you don't
have amazing characters to take you on
the journey so really we look for both
we look for a subject matter that hasn't
been picked over so many times that
people think that they knows that much
about it and you also need these great
storytellers which is part of our
casting process is to find those who can
articulate a journey or can change over
the course of a film and can bring a
subject matter to life I think it would
be almost a Venn diagram actually when
you put it that way which is if there
are both we make a movie about it and
it's it's hard to have both it's it's
unusual which is why we make a film
every couple of years or so because they
don't come along every minute how far
into the process of the film do you know
if the subject is working I know you
talked about Heidi I think with boys of
baraka that you had one subject that
seemed more reluctant but that person
was so fascinating that you really
wanted to keep up with it yeah okay so
and I'm sure that was a painful mistake
cause you probably really wanted that
person in the very much - one the one
that got away
we have learned over a long career that
reluctant subjects are no subjects at
all a reluctant subject it only exists
in your mind he or she will never
participate or allow you the access that
we need in order to make a satisfying
film so we detect very early on by doing
test shoots and allowing people to
saying listen let's come into your house
let's shoot a little bit see how it
feels for both of us because how
reluctant or subject that's too shy
camera shy or too self-conscious
probably won't get over that and so you
have to move on and it can be very very
painful and we don't really make that
mistake too much anymore on this film we
did film several people before we
settled on our final three and one was a
reluctant subject that we spent a couple
of too many days on maybe thinking that
he might come around but he did not so
you keep mate you keep making them
stumbles hopefully you spend less and
less time on the reluctance
object every film well the three
interviews that you have for lack of a
better word subjects are all fascinating
loser re and Eddie and their each one of
their stories are so amazing I want to
know did your angel investor broke to
the idea for approaching footsteps or Oh
wasn't okay so you did a TIF interview
it was on stage and you tell ya it's
great I just seem very observant yeah
yeah sorry it's one of my faults - no
it's she's wonderful on her and she's no
you know what we were already working on
it okay
and that's another sign that we really
want to do something which is when we
just start working on something with no
funding whatsoever and figure out you
know use all of our own resources and
usually when we do that
it works out once in a while we've had
some duds but typically if we're as
excited if we're excited enough that we
have as a subject a character and some
passion it happens so with that we have
a fairly good record of that and in this
case we had just started fishing around
and trying to figure out what our story
was and casting a bit and this wonderful
woman
Regina skully gave us our seed money
okay so what was the impetus for the
idea though I mean you both live in New
York City or on the outskirts
did you see members of the Hasidic
community walking around and just you
were so intrigued by them as we are all
of our films begin with the deep
curiosity for particular Pickers
particular subject or an obsession in
this case Rachael lives in Brooklyn
adjacent to a Hasidic community I live
in an ultra-orthodox neighborhood in
lower Manhattan and so the two of us
have a lot of just had a lot of
interactions small interactions every
day with us in a community but if you
live in New York you ride the subway
with them you might live next door you
might you know during the High Holidays
see them in Mass you know on the street
at a street celebration if you're in New
York with eyes you or you you see the
Hasidic community but you don't know
anyone you don't have any Hasidic
friends you have usually no exchanges
with Hasidic people usually there's not
I
even so it's this population that lives
among us we live among their population
but there's zero contact and then it's
so unusual and so strange because you
know this is not like filming the Amish
you know this is not a remote area this
is the largest city in America and here
we are next to each other not speaking
so for Rachel Knight there was always a
very deep sense of curiosity and
fascination but we never would dare to
try to make a film about the community
because we're to secular women this is a
community does not want to be
photographed that it's very has an
aversion to publicity doesn't watch film
and television that's not looking for
any sort of attention so we we just just
you know we had a fascination that we
let let's stand then we read about
footsteps an organization that helps
people exit the community that's sort of
the Underground Railroad of people that
are trying to transition into a more
secular life and we thought that might
be an interesting jumping-off point to
get to know the community and those
people that are brave enough to try and
get try to leave it and so that really
was our access point we thought if we
could get access to footsteps maybe
there's a movie here and that took about
a year to get access and to start
finding our subjects and it turned out
to be true because through our subjects
you do get a real sense of the Hasidic
community even without official access
in the beginning of your filmmaking how
fearful or brave were you to ask for
more the beginning of our career ask for
more from money our subjects or money or
everything everything I know you had
talked about an interview confidence in
versus being afraid to ask for more
right and that really oh it's like a
light bulb went off because not even
gender specific but just just the fear
of appearing to you know what if we
pushy it is generous is it okay okay
well but but it is getting over that and
I think you talked about how you didn't
even realize that was a thing and you
just kept you were okay with asking for
more and I'd love to hear more about I
think I mean I think a lot of women
professional women have that kind of
trajectory which is you know as
you have more success and you have more
personal confidence you will ask for
more and we were two women we own our
own company we have staff and we've
noticed over the years that the boy
our boy employees will always ask for
more even if they don't deserve it and
the and the women won't so I think part
of it's just you know we also we we
matured and we got more confident but
also we're business owners and I think
you start seeing the world differently
when you are asking for money when
you're taking care of money when you
have staffs working for you when you're
a director you're telling people what
your vision is and expecting them to
they work for you so all of the things
that help people get more confident and
ask for more we were put in a position
that we were able to grow in it so now
that we're almost 30
we're insanely confident we yeah I mean
we have approval it's a privilege to
make documentary films it's a privilege
to be in this business and direct but
there's also a marketplace for the
stories we have to tell there is more of
a marketplace and there's ever been and
so I think a lot of filmmakers
especially earlier in the career just
feels so lucky that anyone is interested
in financing their work or supporting
their work and I totally understand that
but I think it's really important to
graduate into a place where you realize
that everyone with is is moved by
important stories well told and it's
very hard to tell a story and important
story well and so there's a premium for
those people they can do it and it's
important to realize that especially as
a woman director because if you don't
ask it will not be offered to you so you
have to know that and to you know make
demands that are reasonable that are
fair and so you don't just end up you
know working for less or or
feeling less than so we can't wait that
cabin pretty early on in our career I
mean we put our heads down and we work
and we make a movie that's what we do
but we also know that this is important
work that that people want to see and
will and will pay for and that sort of
thing so it's really fine finding that
balance between doing subjects that
really interest us and also realizing
that it is a business as well so then
asking for more being given somewhat
access to footsteps I think you'd said
maybe that they let you sort of be in
the lobby for a little bit it was like
sort of baby steps with them and I don't
I mean that was the access that they
gave us that was it yes okay they they
gave us the ability to meet their
clients that's what we were asking them
for we did not film inside footsteps
hardly ever except a couple of
one-on-one sessions which you see in the
movie right and they're excellent by the
way Oh things were hard-fought scenes
thank you those were hard to get very
very hard to get I can see why yeah so
we weren't at we weren't asking them for
more that's all we needed from them so
we were very persistent and patient and
you know gave them a good pitch of why
we were the right people for them to
trust and they did it and then we met
their members and we kept our end of the
bargain and we made a movie that they
like and they can use in any way they
want so we all we all got something out
of it which is another thing that you
understand as you get more seasoned that
everyone is doing something for their
own incentive and you have to figure out
what that incentive is and also in terms
of asking for more I mean they had been
contacted by other filmmakers multiple
filmmakers over the years and they had
said no and so we said but you haven't
been contacted by us and we have a body
of work to show so it's not abstract so
much they could see all of our past
films are five plus feature-length
documentaries plus a lot of their work
and they can judge for themselves you
know how big of a risk is this footsteps
took a big risk they had no editorial
control over the film they were not
invited for any editorial feedback and
so they had to trust that at least these
filmmakers didn't have a
agenda and would tell it like it is
which is all we can guarantee and so
they kind of jumped off a cliff as well
and you know that's what it takes it's
like it takes really really brave
individuals that will trust you and
organizations in order for this
documentary thing to even happen and we
rely on on people to trust us and rely
on goodwill and we take it as a big
responsibility and as a big gift and it
can be a heavy burden because people
have trusted you and entrusted you with
their secrets and their stories and so
that has not gotten easier that is just
you know something that we grapple with
every time are we doing right by this
person is this did this person mean to
say that or is this the one day that
they would say such a crazy thing that
would be great in the movie but they
actually don't really mean it
so you have to sort of also suss out you
know what what is representative of a
person or an organization so so that we
had a lot of those sort of you know we
had to grapple with a lot of those sort
of rocky moments on this particular
movie and in following the three are a
loser and Eddie how long were you
filming them because I saw such an arc
and how they changed I was it was almost
like there were different people by the
end of the film from my eyes I don't
know if that was really where it was but
from the first initial sort of scenes
with them to the end I felt there were
different people we've done with them
for about a year and a half okay yep in
and out over a year and half but they
you know we're all in New York so we had
a very luxurious opportunity where we
could pop in when we wanted and it
wasn't not like a huge big deal to go
and shoot for you know three hours with
one of them so that was a real bonus I
don't think an non New Yorker could have
made this film you had you had to be
living in New York City to make at least
a film that we made so you do have an
excellent body of work and that's
probably one of the reasons that
footsteps you know they saw your track
record they saw that you had not only
excellent films but films that had a
broad audience most documentary
filmmakers don't get sort of that
opportunity there are done after a few
films it's very hard to make money what
do you think has been maybe not the
secret but the some of the key points in
keeping I mean you both have what over
20 some directing credits yeah okay
that's that's difficult I mean most
people tap out after a few because it is
so hard I think it's I think we probably
both have interesting answers to this
but she wanna go first well I was gonna
say that I think it makes a difference
that there's two of us I really do I
mean it's a lot one of us yeah not just
one of us because you know we we can
support each other and you don't want to
kind of you have someone that you are
accountable to in a lot of ways no one
knows who does what so it's like
everyone has to kind of have their their
top their their game on and I think it's
just a tie yeah I see a lot of our good
friends that are lone wolf filmmakers
and it's hard it's very lonely and you
are creating something from the ether
and no one knows or cares about it until
it's finished and it's it's tough it's
it's not it's not a saw it's not for the
soft it hearted I'd say this particular
this job so I think the fact that
there's two of us and that we help each
other out I think that that has
sustained quite a bit it's for the soft
hearted but not the soft stomach I you
know there's a I think of the type of
documentary filmmaker that will spend
nine years on a subject there's an
incredible devotion and obsession that
most documentary filmmakers have and I
think it's hard to do have them have a
body of work if you have spent eight
years on a subject to get the motivation
do another one I mean I think there's
just a type of person that makes
documentaries that might not be looking
let there a whole career trajectory at
the bottom that the whole you know
future career and we try to look at the
body of work and look down the road so I
think that's helpful to us but you know
we we do feature-length documentary
films that take two or three or more
years to make but we also do
documentaries for television you know
for other clients which are very you
know they can be satisfying and they're
just shorter and maybe less in depth but
we also are doing those well we're
making the other films so it's really
rare for us to just sort of peel off and
not do anything else the two of us for a
period of four years we also have we
have other irons in the fire because you
also have to make a living and so we're
careful about that balance between the
larger feature-length documentaries
which are very precious to us and also
some of the short shorter form pieces
that are are wonderful as well that
maybe take less effort and less time and
there's less shooting days and less
editing so we we take that work as well
and I think you know we have to do that
in order to to make a living and also
you know we like to do things that have
a shorter turnaround that are going to
be brought to an audience sooner as well
there's you'll keep your skills up you
know you have to be able to do all kinds
of work we do commercials every now and
then so you know you want to keep your
muscles going and if you're just in an
edit room for 12 months and you're not
in the field that anymore guess what you
can get rusty you can get rusty if
you're not on the field a lot and you're
I can get soft and I don't know I think
it is something that has to be kept up
and we're able to do that by doing
television work as well as our
feature-length work you have a scene in
the beginning of the film or toward the
beginning where Ari I believe is
speaking to a rabbi and the rabbi is
kind of like talking about human nature
and how it's just part of our make up to
shun those in the sort of quote-unquote
out group maybe it's some a million
trait too and let's do it can you talk
about that and your thoughts on that I
that was a very tough scene for us to
get it was getting people that are in
the community to go on camera speaking
to our characters was extremely
challenging we happened to we got that
we got that scene that's pretty much it
and I I'm glad you noticed it I think
it's really important
that we had it right up front to start
talking about the phenomenon of the
black sheep right up front and not as
something pertaining to their community
but as a universal concept because
that's really what the theme of the film
is is about being an individual versus
being part of a group and what what is
more valuable and what do get more out
of and how different people get
different things out of it and so that
was that's sort of a key at the key
moment when of course being a black
sheep in the Hasidic community is quite
different than being a black sheep at
you know your office party you know but
they're they have things in common
there's correlation the human behavior
there's correlation so I'm glad you
noticed that and then we wanted it to be
right up front so that it was already in
your brain when you started watching the
movie and what this elder in the
community says is there's groupthink and
that is human trait groupthink
you know you're Shawn Shawn or be
shunned and as Rachel said it's more
extreme in this particular committee but
I'm sure there's many people in the gay
and trans community and the evangelical
Christian community doubters in that in
that world that have felt shunned and
for them it's their entire world that
might not be as Extreme as the Hasidic
community but when you're living it
being cast out I think there's a lot of
people that can identify with those
fears that are not religious people and
we hope that these kind of concepts can
jump out of the Hasidic community and
into sort of a more general discourse
that people will see the movie once you
approached foot steps how long before
you had the three main characters in the
film how long did you ask them would
they be willing to about a year it took
us about a year from when we first
approached foot steps until we met our
three main characters because we filmed
some other people before them and for
various reasons we we felt like we had
not found our main characters yet and
when we filmed each one of our
characters that ended up being sort of
the stars of the film we knew right away
so until you
have that feeling like this person this
is the right person you keep trying and
once we had them we stopped looking
you